what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite for callers and their
managers live together under one roof
play a stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion I am
so sick about the vanity and the egos in
Paris that is why next season I'm going
to Miami if you come at Napoli before
proud to get a pizza me ever since I was
a young boy I dreamed playing for you
Liam under culture and just women there
don't overlook Olympiakos
[Music]
a red card this early in the morning I
didn't realize the refs could see into
my dreams I'm afraid it's not that kind
of red card it's worth a yeah yeah hey
so every year the winner of the
Champions League hosts a ball in their
honor I can say from experience it's
usually not very fun for the losers but
this year's different because everybody
loves Liverpool I can feel the
excitement all over the house I'm not
going operas we have to go we have to
show them that we can handle anything
they throw at us even that an
insufferable Liverpool wine fest yes
even an insufferable Liverpool wine fest
[Music]
the festivities are about to begin so
please take your seats what's this we
got no silverware Barcelona we didn't
mean to put you in front and center but
unfortunately all the corners were taken
too quickly before we begin or to thank
a special person without whom we would
not be here today
mr. loris Carius thank you for showing
our American overlords the importance of
spending a lot of money on a competent
kiba well we've got some special treats
for you tonight folks
Liverpool greats old and new to share
with us their favorite memories and what
this title means to them first up
Captain Fantastic himself Steven Gerrard
thanks okay well next up is Robbie
Fowler moving on now to number cata
sigmah top 50 list of Liverpool inside
jokes that only true Scouts as it
understand Evelyn's we haven't saying
just start the new - alien on English
you'll never walk alone
and that is why we need more Liverpool
players in the media we should never
have to talk about bleeding hell
seriously we can't just leave not we
must stay because when we win this year
and then they must stay Kevin and then
there was that 2005 Champions League
semi-final against Chelsea
what's the Macedon Pass you look like
you've seen a ghost of Liverpool switch
bloody wankers am i right and now we'd
like to play a special video to show you
why in Riverview
this means more welcome to Liverpool
where everything matters
a little more as a teams have supporters
we have a family other teams have
managers we have a guardian angel with
perfect teeth we are the most special
team in the most special city with the
most fun likeable players and the
catchiest songs we are Liverpool this
means more your team means less
please give me a red card I'll do
anything anything just please eject me
ma'am now you're very lucky cuz we
caught a very special musical guest a
legendary Liverpool musician let's give
it up for Jamy Webster you don't know
Jamie Webster
my heart's full of Liverpool if I die
I got you heaven and Hermes actually I'm
feel to God it's Robbie Fowler Bosola
mashallah I love you so much I'll eat
your pokémon's painful everyone else is
leaving yes but we're not like everyone
Raza remain classy don't let them break
you
well that was truly unbelievable and now
I want to do a toast to the incredible
feat of winning the Champions League and
doing so without spending all the money
that manchester city spends oh my god
it's like a fantasy land over there am i
right so let's all raise our tops
is there anything sweeter than drinking
from old big ears I can think of one
thing but of course Liverpool
doesn't look at the table as is
seriously so self-absorbed no wonder
everyone hates Minh City
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up YouTube hit subscribe to
support the champions and you'll
instantly be more committed to be our
football than I am to Tonya